hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy where we talk to influential
people in the education space
today we are happy to welcome ben gomes
who's the senior vice president of the
learning and education organization at
google before we get into talking to him
i want to remind you that we are a
non-profit here at khan academy and a
lot of our work is possible because of
donations from folks like you so we
encourage you if you are in a place to
do so to find our site and
give what you can to keep supporting our
work
in addition
as the pandemic has uh has happened we
have needed some additional support to
be able to continue to provide the
education experiences to students who
need them and we want to specifically
recognize corporations who have provided
that support including bank of america
at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors thank you
in addition to this live video feed you
can also get an audio version of our ed
talks and homeroom with sal
in podcast form wherever you find your
podcasts look for homeroom with sal and
you will find us there
so with that i want to
welcome our guest today
ben gomes as i said the senior vice
president of education and learning at
google
ben welcome
uh thank you for having me here
christian and i also just want to take
the opportunity as i saw the intro of
thanking us khan academy for the amazing
work you've been doing for so long and
especially during the last year it's
just it's just wonderful
well thank you and we are happy to do it
let's start off tell us a little bit
about your journey how have you come to
lead the learning and education group at
google how what's you've been your path
to get here
you know if i think about a lot of my
career a lot of it has been about
learning and curiosity you know i spent
20 years in search at google and when i
thought about search a lot of it for me
was about
being able to answer that curiosity of
the moment being able to get that answer
really quickly it's that it stimulates
more curiosity hopefully in the long run
you know
and after working on search for 20 years
i wanted to focus on learning more uh
learning and education more sort of
broadly across google's products and if
you think about google as a whole
google's mission is to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful
but a lot of information is used for
learning
and it's used for changing you know what
people can do in the long run and
a subset of that is education where it's
structured and you get a credential at
the end of it
so uh there's a lot of aspects of
google's products that can be used for
that purpose whether it's search or
youtube or classroom
uh
or g suite and so on a workspace and so
on um that can be used uh for learning
education i was really interested in
that and i think it's a core part of
google's mission
so i think you know it's a for me it was
a really
interesting it it was following a path
that i've
always been interested in in some form
or the other
and uh you know taking it to a deeper
level
got it great
tell us a little bit about your
education journey were there any
particular teachers who were
particularly influential to you in your
success
uh definitely well first of all my mom
uh she was a school teacher uh
and uh she taught geography which is a
subject i don't think that's taught in
the united states but you know she was
really influential in like stimulating
curiosity because she'd take us out into
a
uh an area and then say you know how do
you think this this landscape came to be
and it got you thinking about like how
could this have happened and you know
you may not know the exact answer
but just that process of thinking was
really great and there were other
teachers in my school
uh there was
a just a priest who really influenced my
thinking about you know the importance
of
service and serving others and there was
a there's a chemistry teacher who
influenced not just me but a whole
generation of students in my school
uh to go into the sciences
he was a disciplinarian you know in a
mole that's not common today but his
passion for chemistry was so evident and
he encourages so much to do projects
into play
that a lot of us came to love chemistry
and through chemistry to love science
uh because of that
that's great
so
thinking about the field of education
and the intersection with technology
technology is changing
obviously very quickly but we've seen
some huge advances how do you think we
can
bring those together and what
opportunities are there because of what
technology and the improvements in
technology we've seen
well uh i think we're here we want need
to figure out how to help teachers
in in in all kinds of different ways
right because um uh
the the key things that we have tried to
do in google is to try and understand
where we can help teachers and learners
actually um
focus on the learning and teaching task
at hand right and so that's a core part
of
how i we want to think about the use of
technology in this space
uh as a tool to help you know uh to help
people whether it's the teachers or the
students to get what they're trying to
do done
and so um you know tools like classroom
are really structured around trying to
make the teachers workflow process
and the students workflow process easier
in giving out assignments and quizzes
and all these sorts of things
and the uh and i think there are other
ways in which also you can begin to use
technology
um uh in in more complex ways in your
domains but the first aspect of it is
trying to figure out what do teachers
need what are what is the need of the
day that we can actually provide using
technology so i think it starts with a
teacher and what they need
and then it proceeds from there to the
to the tools that need to be built to to
satisfy their needs
um and i think that's such a
that's such a good point we often see
kind of technology coming in to tell
teachers what they need as opposed to
asking them how are you going about
finding out what teachers
need so i mean it's a it it's a great
great question i mean i in an ideal
world uh having taken on this role i'd
have loved to go into into classrooms
and actually ask teachers in person but
you know i took on this job in the
middle of code where that's not been a
possibility but we do get a lot of user
feedback from teachers we have a lot of
forums with teachers and so on and
you know and so we get a lot of feedback
when you use that really strongly to
prioritize what we're working on
because that feedback coming from
teachers we can't we can't satisfy all
the needs that they have but we
prioritize based on what they are
telling us is most important to them
what causes them the most problems and
what would help them the most in solving
those problems
that make sense
so
what are some of the things that you see
your group there at google working on in
the future
um so there's some very interesting
products that you know first of all
there's
further generations of further
iterations of classroom right like we
just announced 50 new features in a
couple of months ago that we are still
in the process of rolling out some have
rolled out already some will be rolled
out but there are many other there are
other areas too uh we have an app uh
called read along uh which is being used
uh
to help uh children learn to read what
it does is it does speech recognition
and voice and synthesis so that a child
can reading some text can get some
feedback on whether you're doing it
correctly or not
and
we're working together with the
non-profit called pratham uh to actually
uh see whether we
do to see to try and change outcomes and
literacy levels for children and we've
been able to see like even a short time
period an improvement in literacy
uh with this non-profit working with
this tool to help improve outcomes so i
think there's a lot of different ways in
which in the future we can begin to use
technology to help
uh in in more
in deeper ways in the classroom in in
in
in helping the student get feedback and
in helping the teacher give out
assignments and so on in a in in a way
that is effective
uh is more effective than um
than would be possible otherwise
yeah so one of the
things that we can think about
technology doing is maybe helping expand
the classroom expand out into the world
do you think there are opportunities
there
yeah you know the
the role of technology today is it has
changed
what technology is capable of doing
today has changed a lot um you know when
computers first started they were very
good at doing things that humans were
terrible at doing uh you know large
computations complicated mathematics
which we are terrible at doing
but they were terrible at doing things
that
we are capable of doing uh like
understanding that that you know
something is a chair that was an
unsolved computer vision problem for a
very long time but today uh technologies
became beginning to be able to do things
like that so you know recently i got
interested in in botany you know in time
of kobe you're not able to do that much
i go for walks and we all get new
hobbies yeah
yeah i've never been interested in
nature although i'm in california i'm
not a nate i'm not an outdoor kind of
person and i don't much care for
exercise so the um but going on walks i
was like well what's around me is plants
and trees and so i began to be
interested in like well what are the
types of plants and trees i'm seeing
around me you know and there's an app on
google called google lens that allows
you to then take a picture of a plan and
it'll tell you what it is
and you know
10 years ago when i tried this or even
five years ago this stuff didn't work
really well and today it works really
well so you can look at a plant and
begin to figure out what it is and uh
and then
go further from there into like okay
what are the kinds of plants i'm seeing
why are these plants here and so for me
it's just a journey of curiosity but you
can see how
uh something that is
a tool can help me
follow that path of curiosity that i had
and so i think there are these
connections in the real world that
computers are now able to do that would
be really useful another example is uh
our use of ar in
augmented reality models that we
provided in in search for things like
the skeleton which allow uh
students to visualize a skeleton or
parts of the body
you know in the context that they are in
without in a place where they may not
actually have access to an actual
skeleton in their classroom right which
is which is often a useful teaching aid
so there are many different ways in
which you know computers are now able to
connect to the real world that i think
could be of service in a in a classroom
and could be something that teachers
might find useful
that makes sense that makes sense
so we have a couple questions coming in
um we have an interesting question from
susanna garcia dominguez on youtube
um
she says that
in that google is the backbone of our
internet experience are people getting
smarter
she wonders
you know i it's a really interesting
question um and i think from my
here's my perspective when i as i use
search
there are times in the past when i would
uh
hit a wall in what i needed to know to
take the next step right i'm interested
in some area the botany example is one
example but many other areas i'm
interested in and then i'm interested in
one some aspect of it in the past you'd
have to go to the library find a book
and actually then read up about it and
most of the time you just didn't do that
so but today you can ask that question
and get an answer quickly and then
decide if you want to take that interest
further so to my uh to my thinking at
least for me personally it feels to me
that it allows me to develop this kind
of curiosity and exploration
that allows my mind to develop in a
slightly different way than it could
have if every time i was interested in
something it meant finding either the
expert in it or going to a library to
find the right book that's often the
right situation situation once i've
gotten a little bit of
initial interest right the expert will
give you something that probably a book
cannot and a book will give you
something that you know a quick answer
want but but still there is something
about being able to follow those lines
of uh curiosity i think
that
makes us
uh more curious in the future uh helps
us build that muscle within us of
curiosity and i think to me that's a
part of learning i think that's that's
that's really um
the most uh inspiring the most fun and
why and and how it can be something that
we pursue all through our lives
it's interesting we had a guest on
yesterday who's a cognitive scientist um
and uh we were also talking about
curiosity and that um
it's it can be powerful but also fragile
and that we see it in um
young kids so often and that then it
kind of uh you know as we get to be
adults we lose some of that wonder and
he was talking about the fact that you
know we are curious about things that we
think we will help us learn something
new about something we already know
um and so that strikes me as related to
you know this idea of can we use the the
internet and the information to um as
you said hey i know a little bit about
this plant and i want to find out a
little bit more um and build on kind of
that piece that i know
so it seems like that that's a powerful
idea that's keeping people curious as
they get older is that that kind of
maintaining curiosity resonate with you
very much so and i like that notion of
like there are certain seeds of
curiosity in our everyday lives and the
question is whether those seeds find
nutrition
uh and
and and we can and when we can follow
where they whether okay i'm gonna mix
metaphors terribly here where that takes
us
um uh so
i think that that sense of wonder also
about the world around us that sense of
the the amazingness of like
uh of life of nature
all of those things can can inspire
things within us in a moment that can
then lead us on to something uh that
lasts for for longer
that makes sense
i'm gonna shift gears a little we have a
a question uh coming in from uh lek
menkowitz uh
actually a suggestion but i think it
raises a question uh suggestion was you
should talk to teachers worldwide not
only in the u.s
the learning and teaching process
nowadays is less focused on assignments
and quizzes we need different tools but
i'll broaden that out too how are you
thinking about working with teachers
globally or internationally
uh it's it's really important to us and
we actually do have forums that reach
out worldwide we've uh uh we've you know
i
from a personal point of view i've
always been interested in education in
the context of india because that's
where i grew up
and uh i've been uh it's something i was
a bit more familiar with uh but i do
think uh
especially during core during covet uh
learning education has been experienced
also differently in different places and
countries are taking different paths and
so we're very aware of that we're
working with places we're working with
say like the indonesian uh
ministry to figure out how we can deploy
classroom and make it really useful in
that context we're we're we're thinking
about we're working in india with things
like read along this there's a lot of
different things that are needed in
different contexts and we're we're
thinking about those
uh that that range of needs and what we
can build that will satisfy broad needs
around the world but also specialized
needs in particular places that that
arise
yeah that
that is that different context is so
important they mentioned you know the
importance of tests and quizzes and that
is something that you know is it's quite
different in different education systems
and how they think about summative tests
and and even things like the size of
classrooms can make a difference it
seems like um yeah how do you think
about you know kind of just assembling
speaking of information assembling all
that information together to kind of get
your you know build your knowledge base
there
you know i think um i mean i'm acutely
aware of the difference having come from
a different educational system myself
and so
um i think that
in many ways we are looking at
education in various countries
from the countries like brazil indonesia
india to get a sense of what is
happening in different places what the
needs are in different places
in many places the these the the way
education works is driven by uh sort of
the gov by policy
uh by government policy and so we need
to understand what's happening in these
different countries on a country by
country basis and so we're looking at it
in those terms
got it that makes sense
so here's a again a bit of a different
question but i think i'd be interested
to hear what you have to say from let me
see who is asking jennifer zhao on
facebook um what do you think are key
skills students should learn to be ready
for the future
you know at the end of the day
the future is going to be ch
changes faster at a faster and faster
pace right so one of the key skills i
think is getting comfortable with
learning which is why i come back to the
notion of curiosity because that's what
makes learning fun
because if it's it's self-driven and
it's driven by curiosity it makes
learning fun but that also enables you
to like continue to learn over time
and so i think the key skill ends up
being a little bit meta in my view
it is that
it is that ability
to continue to learn
uh and and to some extent some of the
particulars continue to be important you
know language is going to continue to be
important mathematics and some of the
science and the sciences and so on
continue to be important right but uh as
foundational but beyond that i think
there are different skills that we need
at over time
that are going to be hard to predict
right now and so being flexible and
adaptable
to that future i think is going to be
really important for people to
not just survive but thrive in that
future
so another concern about the future is
um equity and
leveling the playing field is there a
role for technology there
you know there are lots of ways in which
we're thinking about this like one
example is um
is uh how do we is in during covet like
a lot of places don't have access to the
internet they don't have wi-fi access or
you know or or high-speed
or phone access
and so we have been working on making
much more of us of our apps be available
offline so that people can do work
offline when they're not connected it's
an example of the kinds of things that
need to be done to enable that kind of
ability to use these tools we've also
been working with indonesian government
on like data availability we've been
working uh with the with making more
chromebooks available in in california
during covet so we're working on like
the overall set of tooling so that there
are the the basic sets of tools are more
broadly available and i think uh that's
that's really an important aspect of
making education work for everybody
yeah absolutely
do you think there's um
things that
when we think about in the tools um
there's something that you know things
as we're as you're thinking about new
tools that you're creating i know there
are concerns as we get more and more
machine learning and ai
that you know are we training them the
right ways are we you know just
replicating our existing biases in these
new forms there are ways we can think
about making sure we're not doing that
you know that's a really important
question and we we work pretty
there's a lot of work going on both in a
research sense as well as in deployment
to make sure
to ensure that we have
um
uh
we do build more models and so on that
don't reflect you know biases in society
it's it's it's it's complex work that
involves both a research component as
well as uh
uh as well as a deployment component and
a lot of work is happening around on
that in in in many different areas and
so i think that's an area of concern and
it's an area that a lot of people are
paying
deep attention to
yeah definitely
so
as you think about
your team and
building out your team what other kinds
of skills
and
um capabilities that you look for in
in as you're building your own teams
you know i was talking about the
the teacher who inspired me who was
really passionate about chemistry
and i looked to a certain extent for
that passion about
the topic
because i think anything we do has
difficulties i think some things work
out some things don't and having that
passion enables people to like go
through those difficulties work with
them
deal with you know when things don't
work out uh because you have that larger
goal in mind of like what you're trying
to
uh
trying to trying to do
and so i think that that's an important
uh aspect of what i look for in
in the this
in people who are working in this
organization and i think you know it it
it holds for many different parts of of
the two kinds of tools we're working on
so this includes things like google
scholar which is used by researchers and
the people working on i use it a lot
yeah the people are extremely passionate
on about
making researchers lives more productive
having them get more access to papers
and and all the sets of things that make
uh research and the information needed
for research more available and useful
google arts and culture is trying to get
um is getting a whole ba working with
cultural institutes to make um those
sorts of experiences more available to
people around the world and all of this
these things are not necessarily always
easy to do
they take a knowledge they take a
certain degree of humility because
we don't know uh what is often needed in
many of these areas
so in the la in in the area of
of education
i i want to understand what teachers
need right in the area of scholar
they're trying to understand what
researchers need so in each of these
areas the thing i'm looking for also is
that a certain degree of humility in
trying to
understand what people's needs are so
that we can actually
serve those needs
that makes sense so kind of looking for
folks that have that um
user-centric uh yes or uh uh ideas that
make sense yes and google has this you
know focus on the user and other things
will follow but it's uh
and it's something that i i really do
believe in like it's it's in whether
it's a teacher or the student
we have to focus on what they need
we have one more question about you
um coming in from youtube uh susannah
garcia dominguez asks what sacrifices
have you made in your own journey to get
where you are today
you know it's an interesting it's an
interesting question i think
i've been very fortunate in my life
in uh in uh
in some of the choices i made
but i did choose to go into computer
science at a time
when it wasn't it was something that was
a passion for me but was not really um
that uh
um
that widely um
it was not that that uh
important uh an area
i you know i think when i tend to think
of it i don't tend to think of
sort of uh i didn't think of other
people's sacrifices as being far greater
than my own the sacrifices sort of that
my parents made that teachers around me
made
i feel i've been
really fortunate and a beneficiary of
a lot of
um
what other people around me have done
and i feel the need to serve others
as a result of that because i think uh
it's it's it's it's it's
uh you know there's a there's a lot of
uh there's a lot that other people from
my you know including my parents and so
on have done
i think that i have benefited from and i
think it it that that's a thought that
that stays with me quite often
yeah yeah tell me a little bit more
about um now computer science of course
is where everyone says oh if you want to
you know
be successful and be you know attached
to the future go into computer science
um but it's interesting that when you
were starting out that was not the case
so
was it something that you were just
really interested in or what made you
pursue that even though it wasn't maybe
being the as popular then
yeah when i was going when i was when i
started out a lot of people were
those people who tried were persuading
me to try and go into one of the
fields like medicine or law or things
like that but my own interest was in
building things
i think some inherent inherently there's
an engineer in me and so this that
aspect of building things was something
that always appealed to me
and so computer science was something
that
uh inherently just repealed the first
time i saw a computer and so it was
something that uh drew me
uh very early on and it's something that
that that that pleasure of building
things i think is something that of
creating or building something is
something that doesn't go away from you
because i think it it plays it can play
a role in your life all the way through
in small things or in in larger
ways got it
what advice would you have for learners
that are you know just now kind of
coming up and thinking about
their future education and their future
careers
i think this uh
what has served me well actually is a
breadth of interest
because you know when i started working
even at google i worked on uh
infrastructure infrastructure projects
within google on pagerank and things
like that i worked on ranking
but then i began to be involved with
user interfaces and things of that sort
but what i felt what that served me well
was finding out what's interesting in
that area
and then and then being able to pursue
it so i would say
uh find the interesting thing in almost
anything that you
are learning
and pursue that it it gets to what makes
learning i think interesting and fun and
not just a task
so that's the piece and then when it is
interesting when it is more uh when it
is more than just a task to do
i think you get much more out of it
and uh and uh not just in the short term
but in the long term
great
that seems like good advice for us to
end on so thank you so much for joining
us today we appreciate having you
thank you so much christian for having
me here
great and to all of our guests thanks
for joining us today all of those out
there listening and we will see you next
time
you